- [Voiceover] All right grammarians,
let's get down to it,
and start talking about
possessive pronouns.
A possessive pronoun is a pronoun
that we use to show
possession of something
which is just sort of
a fancy way of saying
"you have it."
So possession equals having stuff.
Now we can essentially divide
possessive pronouns in half,
because on this side of the divide,
we have a list of pronouns
that behave like adjectives,
and on this side,
we have a group of pronouns
that behave like nouns.
I'll list them and then
we'll give some examples.
So the possessive pronoun
that behaves like an
adjective for me is my.
The possessive pronoun
that behaves like a noun for me is mine.
Our behaves like an adjective;
ours behaves like a noun.
Your behaves like an adjective;
yours behaves like a noun.
Her behaves like an adjective;
hers behaves like a noun.
His behaves like an adjective;
his behaves like a noun.
Its behaves like an adjective;
its behaves like a noun.
And their behaves like an adjective,
and theirs behaves like a noun.
Now I'd like to point out that nowhere
in any of these words does there appear
such a thing as an apostrophe.
That little guy.
I know this much is true:
there are no apostrophes
in possessive pronouns.
So it's not ours,
it's ours, like that.
It's not yours with an
apostrophe like that,
it's yours with no apostrophe.
Likewise it's not
hers, his,
it's is the big one.
That means something entirely different.
Or theirs.
Across all varieties of English,
the possessive pronouns don't
have any apostrophes in them.
So this is a very handsome looking chart
if I do say so myself,
but it doesn't really do the work
of explaining what I mean
by saying my behaves like an adjective,
and mine behaves like a noun.
So let me get some example sentences down
and we'll see what I mean.
So let's say that there
was a book that I owned.
How would I talk about it?
Well I could do it two different ways
using these possessive pronouns.
I could say, "That is my book."
And here my is working as an adjective
that modifies and describes book.
Or I could say, "That book is mine."
And here we're using is
to connect book to mine,
and so in that case we're
using mine as a noun.
How do we know it's acting like a noun?
Because we can use it
independently of the word book.
So if someone says to me,
"David, where is your book?"
I can say, "Mine is on the bedside table."
Nowhere in this sentence
does the word book appear,
but we can use mine independently
because we've established
in a previous sentence
that the thing we're
talking about is this book.
So let's talk about my coworker Girish.
Nice fella.
And let's say that Girish
has a very nice hat.
"We would say,
"That is Girish's hat."
This is what we'd call a possessive noun.
But talking of Girish again, we could say,
"That is his hat."
Now we're using that possessive
pronoun as an adjective
to modify hat.
Whose hat is it?
It is his hat.
If we wanted to use the personal pronoun
that acted like a noun,
we would say, "That hat is his."
And we can also use his
independently of the word hat
by saying, "His is the
hat with polka dots."
So we've got two piles of
possessive pronouns here.
And one pile behaves like adjectives:
my, our, your, her, his, its, their,
and the other behaves like nouns:
mine, ours, yours, hers,
his, its, theirs.
And remember, none of them
contain an apostrophe.
You can learn anything.
David out.